being a part of hidden figures was the
very first time I was a part of an
oscar-nominated film you will never
forget that first moment in your career
[Music]
it was a real Oscar obsessed kid so it's
hard for me to choose a moment when Anna
Paquin went for the piano because I was
the same age as her and I really wanted
to be an actress I was so jealous of her
the first thing that came to mind was
Roberto Bernini me too Roberto benini
when he won the Oscar for life is
beautiful and he's jumping over the
seats Sam Rockwell waiting for a three
Billboards early 1990s when Jack Palance
did one-handed push-ups at age 70
something Stanley donut was the director
of the show and he insisted that the
three gentlemen gave the best picture
Oscar would be John Houston Billy Wilder
and the Kira Kurosawa you could feel the
warmth and self-respect for the movie
business in that moment an Oscar moment
that speaks to me was Sally Fields
except in speech I can't deny the fact
that you like me my former television
mother Sally Field they like me they
really like me Madonna singing sooner or
later from Dick Tracy on the Oscars is
probably the best musical performance on
the Oscars ever the moment when the
times of Harvey Milk won you made me
realize that I did want to make
documentaries Boo and Whoopi Goldberg
won her Oscar it's a really memorable
moment for me Ben Whoopi Goldberg won
for Ghost and closed the gap of so many
years without a black actor being on
that stage when Halle Berry won um best
actress and that was the first time that
a woman of color had won it was quite
significant this moment
so much bigger
than me I have many memories having
grown up on the Oscars but it was pretty
extraordinary to get to have my birthday
at the Oscars and win the Oscar for Noah
bombback's marriage story The Streaker
stands out to me one of those things was
a plan was it spontaneous and we don't
know who cares that stays in my mind
foreign
[Music]